bindi Irwin has taken her Mirrorball
trophy back home to Australia and that's
where she gave her dancing partner Derek
Hough
big cuddly surprise it's one of the
coolest things I think that's ever
happened I think to have a name an
animal name to have you is amazing it's
the coolest thing come on that's cute
holy EG said accrue as derek got an up
close and personal look at the Australia
Zoo in Queensland and we mean really up
close when it came to this Burmese
python look at that he's like climbing
up your shoulder it was a pretty good
sport getting a no job job the green
iguana they like dinosaur that they like
this this is ancient lizard and he fed
this echidna its favorite fruit of bugs
and ground-up grubs they kind of look
like a pincushion and they have a really
long tongue really love can you feel
that back home and oz bindi is in her
element and Derek showed no fear until
he met this Gator as it gets warmer he
gets more active since winning that
mirror ball trophy bindi is happy to be
home and quite a bit richer a Los
Angeles judge has approved her dancing
contract worth a reported $350,000 the
money for the 17 year old had been held
up until the court had proof her father
Steve Irwin was deceased
and as far as a future career in front
of the cameras we have a few projects
all over the place on the horizon so I'm
excited about that and we'll see where
life takes me but for me my heart will
always lie in conservation and wildlife
work so as long as I'm doing that I'll
be happy just being around the dingoes
and macaws you can see bindi has the
same loving touch for father head and we
had to have her set the record straight
about the wild rumor she's getting
married to her boyfriend Chandler Powell
I actually found out about my generous I
got home I can't have a ring or a knee
okay but you know it's great to find out
you know me 17 is the new Betty